also ich kann nicht wirklich richtig
aufregen denn wenn ich im urlaub war
dann muss sich dreimal anstehen ich muss
an stehend beim check-in ich muss an
steht eine sicherheit am ende am
kofferband ich hab selbst mitgemacht da
pulsiert wirklich der da geht mein
blutdruck hoch wirklich ich habe angst
dass ich mein flieger vielleicht
verpasse aber das ist doch wirklich kein
urlaub und jetzt als letzte möglichkeit
holen wir jetzt 4000 der gastarbeiter
aus der türkei hierher hier gibt es doch
genug menschen die ja auch arbeiten
wollen wenn die löhne halt stimme ich
habe mir angeschaut so ein
sicherheitsbedienstete an der
fluggastkontrolle der verdient 2400 euro
brutto das ist doch gar nix ich kann das
auch verstehen dass sie dann abgewandert
sind die logistik der dhl boote krieg so
minimum
3200 also ich finde faire löhne müssen
da einfach sagen dieses flugchaos ist
wirklich eine schande für deutschland
wenn ich da stehe ich fühle mich da
körper verletzt also nicht regt das
total auf wir kommen einfach nach
coroner nicht wieder richtig in den
tritt und das muss wirklich ein ende
haben
bravo
herr stellung zu der bruder sie haben
vollkommen recht nur mich überrascht mal
wieder dass sie überrascht sind wir
wissen sie ich nehme an mit dem ende von
corona hat niemand gerechnet so wie
putin nicht damit gerechnet dass die
ukraine die leute ganz zu hause und
machen sich ein ja genau ans gehen und
jetzt glaubt niemand wusste auch mal in
diesem land ein feld das die
urlaubssaison anfängen dass wir ein
system sei anfällig ich war jetzt zwei
drei mal am berliner flughafen
versuche das nie wieder zu tun dass
steht übrigens auf meinem blacklist ganz
oben
ich bin neulich ich bin neulich ein
regionalzug ist nach warschau gefahren
das war haben wir niemals da schlange zu
stehen aber es waren alle überrascht
verstehen sie das ist das land der
absoluten kompetenz wenn die nicht mal
wissen dass im sommer leute reisen und
wir haben doch einen verkehrsminister
und die ministerin ich weiß dass ich
kein west wir haben herr wissing von der
fdp wissen und sagt das herzmittel ist
dass ich
nicht mehr es ist hier nahmen sie
gefeuert nein es ist ja eine neue
regierung und der neue regierung
gemacht ein paar monaten habe es nicht
gemacht ich war für uns
aber das ist eigentlich fast ein
bisschen schlimm weil sie können jetzt
nicht dafür verantwortlich machen sonst
ging es ist ein eher scheuer sie meinen
der show wurde begnadigt bevor ich zum
verfahren kommen ja nein das würde ich
nicht sagen dass der halbe milliarde
euro vergeudet mit seinem wunderbaren
maut flammen damit kommt man hier davon
ich würde sagen dass er auf einem plan
halten der nicht aufgegangen ist aber
ich möchte noch einmal zu dem urlaubs
chaos zurückkommen frank du hast ja
gesagt dass wir hier genügend leute
haben in deutschland die arbeiten wollen
wie kommst du darauf ich muss ich muss
sagen ich habe das gelesen und dachte
mir erst mal die idee ist doch gar nicht
so schlecht der politik zu sagen wir
holen arbeiter per wir wollen arbeiten
nach deutschland dies machen möchten wir
haben ja auch gerade nicht eine eine
exorbitant hohe arbeitslosenquote in
deutschland also wo liegt ein problem
mit den gastarbeitern finde ich habe
hilfe an den vorschlag gar nicht gegen
die gastarbeiter
lena ich finde nur halt wenn du für 2400
euro die ich habe folgen lassen muss ich
will auch sauer ehrlicherweise bin ich
auch immer schlecht gelaunt wenn ich an
der sicherheitskontrolle stehe und das
willst du dir halt am ende auch nicht
geben wahrscheinlich und dann lief es
auch gehört haben die mitarbeiter sind
dann abgewandelt andere branchen und
jetzt stehen wir alle da und wir wussten
dass gar nicht wie gesagt nicht
überhaupt gibt es doch gar nicht kann
ich mir nicht vorstellen dass ich es
wieder reisen ja genau das sind doch
schleppern und jeder annabi sei die
polit also wie soll die politik das
machen sollte jetzt komplett in löhne
eingreifen einen flughäfen oder wie wäre
das szenario dass mögliches länder
pc-maus außerdem bundesarbeitsminister
wirklich tarifstrukturen zu schaffen
dass der durst dieser job wieder
attraktiv wird also dass das erst muss
das rechnen schon länger damit kann man
doch mal anfangen sie haben dasselbe
problem in der gastronomie sie haben
große gaststätten wird 23 kellner sich
die seele aus dem leib laufen weil die
leute die gekündigt wurde und kurzarbeit
geschickt wurde nicht wiedergekommen
sind ja dass du nicht weg sie haben das
in restaurants hotels überall einen
ganzen dienstleistungsgewerbe ja da hast
du ja auch am ende noch ein bisschen
trinkgeld also am ende wird ja damit
jetzt
wir brauchen wir brauchen fachkräfte
haben wir nicht vor sechs oder sieben
jahren so eine große zuwanderung von
facharbeitern gehabt die uns versprochen
wurde was ist denn daraus geworden ich
habe da auch nichts mitbekommen oder
müssen die ganzen facharbeiter aus 20.15
geblieben da muss man jetzt natürlich
sagen das muss man sich alles immer ganz
genau anschauen im wald waren absolut
muss man differenzen auch die andere
seite hören auch das muss
gut verstanden ja absolut absolute ob
ich ja nur ihretwegen gekommen
aber aber frank du willst ja auch
eigentlich eher dass auch deutsche wenn
ich nicht verstehe diese jobs übernehmen
dass sie wieder attraktiv werden und du
bist für tarifstrukturen absolut und
wenn wir die tarife erhöhen und keiner
will an der sicherheitskontrolle beim
check-in arbeiten dann ist das alles in
gute idee wirklich aus dem ausland und
fachkräfte ranzen aber das müsste man
auch erstmal ausloten
wenn jetzt die fachleute aus der türkei
kommen welcher sprache wollen sie mit
ihnen reden kriege ich ein problem wenn
ich die auf armenisch nedas werden
menschen sein die gut deutsch können
dass ich auch eine voraussetzung das tut
man ja auch nicht da stehen ausbilden
und herrschaften ja ja die sollen
angeblich schon so eine sicherheits
überprüfungen haben also die könnten
wohl wenn ich das glaube was mir heute
erzählt worden ist die sind quasi schon
recht ich mal ein satz wie immer sind
aber doch besser wird jetzt was und zwar
sofort ja bevor wir in tarifautonomie
eingreifen ich glaube das ist eine
schwierige geschichte könnte passieren
dass es überhaupt zu diesem gehört dass
wir haben die götter ehrlich das
verstehe ich und ich hab dann haben euch
mal abgefragt werden haben belegen dass
an
und dann habe ich mal eine kleine
anfrage gestellt an senat quartier wie
sieht es aus das problem sofort nach
berlin geschoben wir haben ja gar nichts
damit zu tun obwohl hamburg ja auch am
flughafen beteiligt ist und natürlich
sind die auch mitverantwortlich die
können sich da genauso darum kümmern und
ich sehe das ein bisschen so wie sie die
sagen sich okay hier ist ein problem ist
dass man eine zeitlang aus wird sie
schon erledigen natürlich erledigt sich
das nicht aber erst dann ganz richtig
hart auf hart kommen die presse ist
richtig schreibt und wenn überall bilder
noch nicht alle dicke klar logisch aber
in dem fall eben auch und ich finde
ehrlich gesagt da kommt noch was dazu
die menschen haben so lange in der
kommune es hat wirklich zu hause der
rest zum teil einfach eingesperrt ja die
haben wirklich auch wenig kohle moment
und was passiert denn wenn man da am
flughafen steht unseren ticket nicht
zurückhält und wenn man familien urlaub
gebucht hat ich finde das trifft ja
nicht nur uns wo wir uns einfach nur
ärgern was nervt das trifft finde ich
auch wirklich in dem fall schon die
verdammten lang verdienten urlaub
einfach mal antreten möchte mit ihrer
familie vielleicht die ganze woche lang
vielleicht auch richtig darauf gespart
und dann hinterher was das für chaos sie
werden ja nicht nur nicht mitfliegen
sein sie müssen sich dann über die ganze
rückabwicklung auch noch und da muss man
eine entschuldung auch wirklich nennen
und ich sage es ist eindeutig das
innenministerium die fluggastkontrolle
das ist in der regie der bundespolizei
an der politik jemals die schuldigen
genannt oder ist oder zu setzen sagt
sind wir bei den bei den flughafen chefs
die haben auch die köpfe sind jetzt
sagen denn ohne ihr berlin schuld und so
ich kann es nicht mehr hören
es geht ja unterstufen verantwortet lang
berlin ist schuld berlin sagt es liegt
in europa genau europa wird hier und da
nichts an corona dann ist es am koran
aber das ist das prinzip dieser
verwaltung und was sie jetzt mit den
leuten erleben die nicht arbeiten können
oder einfach nicht da sind dann werden
sie den zehn jahren mit dem auto erleben
wenn in zehn jahren die ersten autowerke
zu machen wenn es eine riesige
arbeitslosigkeit deswegen gibt sie
können die leute ja alle zu ihm welt
verändert das ist eine ganz spannende
frage die habe ich auch an sie dann
würden sich auch fragen wie konnte
entkommen nein die das werde ich mich da
wahrscheinlich fragen aber ich habe noch
eine frage an freund treuenfels frowein
und zwar wir haben ja also die ampel
regierung die möchte ja auch die
sanktionen bei hartz 4 aussetzen ich
muss jetzt schon sagen wenn ich jetzt
sehe wir haben viele arbeitsplätze und
wir haben niemanden der es macht ist das
denn aktuell das richtige signal oder
muss man nicht mehr sagen jetzt muss
erst recht noch mehr geleistet werden
sanktionen müssen auf jeden fall beirats
vier bleiben und sonst ab an den
flughafen naja also ab am flughafen dass
wir da will ich jetzt nicht ich finde
das auch schwierig das auto sitzen weil
ich finde diese diese mentalität und
einfach alle zu schonen und zu sagen
gemeldet euch gar nicht mehr ist auch
als mehr dafür tun ich finde es manchmal
seinen eigenen kindern die man muss auch
ein bisschen auf abfordern tja wie ich
so wie sie aber jetzt sozusagen zu sagen
abmarsch ist hat die jetzt 20 am
flughafen da will ich jetzt nicht
mitgehen weil ich habe jetzt müssen die
deutschen noch selber entscheiden aber
dafür dass die hartz iv sanktionen
bleiben ja einfach nicht dafür wenn wir
wir haben erst mit den verbrennern
geredet jetzt sprechen wir über die als
vier sanktion macht die fdp ein wenig
zuviel kompromisse und musste zu viele
kompromisse machen naja man kann diese
frage auch umdrehen und sagen was wäre
wenn wir gesicht dabei werden und ich
glaube ganz das sage ich jetzt nicht um
mich irgendwie raus zu reden dann wäre
die bilanz noch schlechter natürlich
müssen wir kompromisse machen das geht
gar nicht anders ich meine wir haben
jetzt mit 30 prozent oder so gehabt
hätten könnten wir da den eigenen gesang
bestimmen aber so ist es nun mal nicht
ich finde schon man muss kompromisse
machen es gibt bestimmt auch sagen das
war keine liebesheirat das ist einfach
so die cdu war nicht in der lage
irgendwie mit uns verhandeln zu können
sonst wäre das möglicherweise auch noch
anders ausgegangen und jetzt muss man
halt sehen dass man die flocke anschlägt
und dann muss man sich die punkte heraus
suchen bei dem man das hinkriegt und ich
glaube schon
dass das für uns eine position ist die
wir vertreten müssen und die vereinigung
auch in die ampeln vertreten müssen aber
auch ruhig und das tun die grünen ja
auch dauernd sagen übrigens wir sehen
das bisschen anders ich habe jetzt
gerade gestern eine sitzung in der
bürgerschaft das war ganz interessant da
ist es von den grünen immer ja die haben
dass es gegen uns beschlossen worden in
der ampel soll ich mehr setzt euch doch
durch und so ist es ein bisschen also
ich also die ampel wird die
regierungszeit schaffen gemeinsam das
nehme ich mal an schon an dass sie das
schaffen werden also das wäre ja wohl
mal das ziel dass man sich da
zusammenbraut und den bürgern jetzt
gesagt hier wir haben das zu schaffen
wenn ich das dafür sind auch die
herausforderung zu groß und auch
deswegen muss man jetzt auch ein
bisschen kompromisse schließen sie das
auch nicht leicht zu sagen uns was noch
schlimmer ist eine gefährliche moment
wissen ja leute in die sed gegangen was
system von ihnen aufzumischen hat auch
nicht geklappt hat schlimme ist ja ist
es ja moment wir wollen ja immer noch
mal sagen dass wir in einem
demokratischen land leben wo einiges
auch ganz gut nach vorne gehen wir ja
man hier manchmal auf hohem niveau
er hatte wohnungsmangel geht nach vorne
habe jemand noch was anzubieten
wenn sie sinn wenn sie in andere länder
reisen und sich das vergleichen da muss
man schon sagen es ist hier jetzt nicht
ganz so schlecht in deutschland zu leben
das hat mit diesem grund wirklich gut
deswegen sage ich es ist nicht alles
schlimm und ich finde schon dass wir
dafür da sein liberale standpunkte da in
die richtig einzuschlagen also schlecker
anzuschlagen in der regierung das tun
wir auch aber man kann eben einfach
nicht alles haben das ist nun mal so
sind es ein sehr gutes argument in
andere länder reisen ich war jetzt in
kurzer abfolge gegen tel aviv in
reykjavik und in warschau und da können
sie sich wenn sie aus berlin kommen
schreibt ihn von abschneiden gleicher
weise in jeder weise wie man den verkehr
regeln wenn man der stadt sauber hält
wie man kriminalität nicht aufkommen
lässt also seien sie gelernt ja jetzt
nicht ganz mit einer vergleiches ich
nichts miteinander vergleichen und
öffentlich zu sagen nur eine andere
länder fährt kommt zurück meint man im
garten eden zu legen im ganzen habe ich
glaube ich mich nicht sagen hören sagt
ich habe gesagt nein ich erlebe
wir leben hier jetzt auch nicht so
schlecht
nicht so wissen sie was mich immer
wissen was mich mehr verdächtig gemacht
wenn leute sachen dementieren nicht
behauptet wurde
niemand das wäre schlecht legen
vielleicht ein bisschen über unsere
verhältnisse leben über unsere
verhältnisse
wir haben heute habe ich einen bericht
gehört vom paritätischen
wohlfahrtsverband die armutsrate geht
über das auch nach vorne also ich ihnen
dem land gibt es vieles nach vorne und
meistens in die falsche richtung gestern
waren wir am abgrund heute sind wir
schon einen schritt weiter